- [Child] 25, 26, 27...
- [Woman] It is not easy to see them
go through this experience of
actually making the incense.
It's a dark and dingy place
where they are all sitting cramped up,
but when the child goes through
that experiential learning
I see them building empathy
and having gratitude
for their own lives.
I'm really proud that
I'm creating citizens
who are changing the world.
The vision of Riverside is
to create the best school
for the world and not just in the world.
Education is not all about content.
It is about doing good
as well as doing well.
So, right from Grade 3,
we start with this whole
idea of citizenship.
- Citizenship for me is when
you add value to your society
and make it better, the way you want it.
- [Woman] We start by giving
them various experiences
which highlights the problem.
- You recognize a problem around
you and that disturbs you,
then you actually go and experience it.
- Grade 5 we are learning
about child labor.
We learn what is a lifestyle of child
who is making incense sticks.
- Agarbatti is the incense
sticks which we use
especially in our Indian culture.
These incense sticks is
made by these tiny children,
these tiny hands.
- What did we just see?
- That they have to work for so much
and they're not even getting food.
- And the children were
forced to work over there.
- They don't have basically a choice.
- To understand what they
might be going through,
what can we do?
- Agarbatti experience.
- We can experience.
- Children will spend two
days making agarbathis.
That kind of experiential
learning is something which
hits the children the most.
They will understand child
rights and child labor
to a much deeper extent.
- When we watch videos or talk,
we don't get to know what do they feel
and this is like stepping into their shoes
and feeling what they do.
- We want them to see these
are the places where children work.
So you try to make it as
authentic as it can be.
(kids chatting)
- [Woman] Complete silence.
You will be in complete
silence right from here.
No talking to each other.
- [Child] We have a dough of
agarbathi that we have to roll
on a stick and make it.
- [Woman] No smiling.
This is not play time,
this is work time.
- [Child] So the teachers
are acting very strict.
They're not letting us do anything.
It was not normal.
- So, I also want the size proper.
I want the thickness proper.
- You wanna buy this
from market? Would you?
Would your mom give money for this?
- [Woman] Quick, move your hands now.
- No, I don't want to buy this.
- [Woman] Move it!
- [Child] I was feeling very excited that
what is going to happen and
I'm going to have a lot of fun.
- [Woman] Hurry up, Tushya!
- And now I'm really
unexcited and I'm very sad.
I've been having a headache.
My back is aching because of sitting.
- Six hours. How many
agarbattis of quality?
- 10.
- 10. So what's the problem?
You will get water only when
you give me 50 agarbattis
and you will get food when
you make 100 agarbattis.
- We give them two
chapatis, onion and chili,
which actually, a child in a factory gets.
- I was like so happy in that
chapati with chili and onion.
I could eat anything at that time.
- I told my parents that I
don't want to go to school
tomorrow because of the same experience.
Then after thinking sometime,
I thought that I need to experience this,
this is important for me.
- [Child] One, two...
- Right now, we will be
doing the reflection.
What do they feel? Has that
made any difference to them?
- I was feeling very bad.
I was not being treated like a child.
- So, what do you think
children should be doing?
- Go to school, get education.
- What else children should
be getting at this age?
- Playtime.
- Now I'm feeling more
grateful about things
because I know that
everyone doesn't get it.
So, now I'm not wasting things.
- So, when you wrap up the experience,
it is about how would they
like to take it ahead.
Some of them said, "We
want to do a street play
"and we want to make people aware."
- Basically, going back to
the purpose of citizenship,
taking some action to
change that situation.
I believe this is the education.
Through content, the head is growing,
but definitely, you need the heart to grow
and when you get content
and character together,
that's where the change
happens and if we can have all
our children go as citizen leaders,
they will stand up for what is right.